with less than four weeks until the next
eu summit on monday the general affairs
council will examine the draft agenda
for the heads of state who are expected
to make a final decision on the new
climate and energy policy framework
proposed by the european commission to
move towards a low-carbon economy
eu leaders are also expected to discuss
the economic situation in europe as well
as pressing international issues besides
preparing the ground for the next
european council ministers will also
follow up on the strategic agenda
adopted by eu leaders at their last
meeting in june
they will discuss how to accelerate the
implementation of measures aimed at
fostering growth jobs and
competitiveness in europe
with this aim in mind ministers will
discuss a report prepared by the italian
presidency which reviews progress since
the compact for growth in jobs was
adopted two years ago
finally ministers are expected to adopt
conclusions on the eu strategy for the
adriatic and ionian region
the strategy aims at strengthening
cooperation between the eight
participating countries to the benefit
of 70 million citizens
working together to address common
challenges such as preserving the marine
environment promoting sustainable
tourism and completing transport and
energy networks in the macro region